the so-called Golden State Killer will
spend the rest of his life in prison
with no chance of parole after pleading
guilty to murdering 13 people former
police officer Joseph D'Angelo jr.
terrorized California in the 1970's and
80's during a rape burglary and killing
spree he was arrested in 2018 after
evading capture for decades 48 hours
correspondent Tracy Smith has been
following this case for years when he
was wheeled into the hearing yesterday
Joseph D'Angelo hardly resembled the
agile young man who sneaked into homes
to commit murder and dozens of rapes he
repeated the same plea over and over
again prosecutors detailed his horrific
crimes after raping her the defendant
fired his handgun into the back of
Deborah's head the defendant covered
jane doe's face with towels he unbound
her legs and he raped her
D'Angelo's guilty plea will spare him
the death penalty in exchange he
admitted to 13 murders and some 50 rapes
spanning six California counties over
two decades we spoke to D'Angelo's fifth
victim Jayne Carson Sandler back in 2017
for 48 hours her three-year-old son was
in the home when she was raped when the
rape took place I wasn't paying any
attention to it
because all I was thinking about his
where's my son D'Angelo roamed free for
40 years until 2018 when investigators
used DNA evidence to track him through a
popular genealogy website every one of
those victims deserves justice
Sacramento County District Attorney and
Murray Schubert these women in their
significant other standing with them to
take back that power was really
it was really overwhelming to see among
those to stand Chris pedretti one of
D'Angelo's youngest rape victims at just
15 years old he's having to live with
the fact that we're hearing every single
thing that he said and what he did to us
and we are not taking it anymore
for CBS this morning I'm Tracy Smith in
southern california